let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 our first caller today is from the
408 area code caller from 408 tell us
who you are and go right ahead
yeah arnesto we can hear you fine go
ahead I'm Lucas actually I'm very
excited to be here man first question is
I have two questions homie first
question which you answered my question
in Spanish I would not know the audience
would not understand that what's the
second question I believe education is
actually deeper than money in politics
do you agree with this well make the
case for it why is education deeper or
more important than money in politics
because I believe our real problem is
how with you a politics how we are
raised to view politics is somehow a
taboo from here you shouldn't think
about it as religion and I believe we
should learn from very little to
separate politics from feelings and
beliefs and I don't I just feel like our
education system doesn't support the
kind of education we need to be
competent order yeah so here's a I agree
with you I think here's where maybe I
would disagree we need to change the
campaign finance system to change how
politics are done I agree with you that
if people were better educated we might
have more people walking around the
country who want to change the campaign
finance system but here's where I would
disagree with you just having better
educated people won't make it so that
rich and corporations can control
politics through money it might lead to
having more of a desire to change the
campaign finance system so I still think
it's fair to say that campaign finance
and media coverage and the environment
climate change are sort of like the top
three issues but where I agree with you
is that
if we had better educated people people
learning critical thinking from a young
age we would have way more people that
are ready and willing and eager to fix
those three issues well thank you for
your answer Daisy all right Ernesto
great to hear from you that was my
Ernesto's my paternal grandfather's name
he was Ernesto always great to hear from
from fellow Ernesto's